le département des Yvelines ne lance ses
premières assises de l'alimentation et
on retrouve tout de suite Régine ralech
sur place à Thoiry Régine est-ce que
vous m'entendez
oui très bien je suis à Thoiry
actuellement et ce soir c'est le
lancement des premières assises de
l'alimentation et j'avais moi Pauline
vinocourt Lefebvre vice-présidente du
département et délégué à la ruralité à
l'agriculture et à l'alimentation
bonsoir bonsoir est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer en quelques mots en quoi
consiste ces assises nous lançons
une
un temps de concertation et d'échange
avec tous les acteurs
liés à l'agriculture dans notre
territoire pour définir les contours et
les grands axes d'une politique
départementale agricole justement vous
avez huit objectifs phares comment
est-ce que vous les avez défini
alors d'abord en fonction de ce que nous
faisons déjà je pense par exemple aux
cantines scolaires dans lesquelles il y
a quelques années on a souhaité faire
entrer des produits locaux dans les
assiettes des collégiens ou à la
précarité alimentaire qui fait partie du
de notre cœur de métier en tant que
département et ce sont des axes de
réflexion sur lesquels on pense que le
département peut soutenir l'agriculture
et justement vous travaillez avec
l'opérateur c'est midi depuis 2019 pour
offrir une restauration scolaire de
qualité vous prévoyez également un
meilleur approvisionnement local
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement ça
signifie qu'il y a un certain nombre de
freins qui vont devoir être levés pour
permettre un meilleur approvisionnement
et surtout une meilleure sécurisation
des contrats pour les producteurs qui
travaillent avec ces midi
dans les objectifs vous parlez également
de précarité alimentaire alors c'est
lorsqu'une personne n'est dispose pas
d'un accès garanti à une alimentation
suffisante et de qualité comment est-ce
que vous comptez répondre c'est
justement tout l'objet du groupe de
travail sur ce sujet que de voir comment
on peut être efficient en la matière
après les assises il est prévu 4 mois de
concertation dans lesquels vous allez
co-construire justement ces offres
alimentaires comment ça se passe
dérouler et quels sont les grandes
étapes alors c'est pas après les assises
ce sont les assises ce soir ce n'est que
le temps de lancement donc les étapes au
mois de mars les ateliers les 8 ateliers
se réuniront pour la première fois pour
des pour délimiter les contours de leur
valeur permettre d'intervention les
questions qu'il souhaitent aborder des
visites de terrain qu'ils effectueront
ensuite il y aura une ou deux autres
réunions de ces ateliers pour travailler
sur les axes définis lors de la première
réunion et une restitution prévue si
tout se passe bien mi-mai ou fin mai
merci Pauline vinocour Lefebvre je le
rappelle vous êtes
présidente vice-président du département
délégué à la ruralité à l'agriculture et
à l'alimentation
et Merci à VOUS Régine Rallet pour cette
interview